sur fiscale se réjouit évidemment de
révélations nouvelles qui peuvent être
faites sur des schémas d'évasion de
fraude fiscale internationale
donc c'est une étape supplémentaire 1
par rapport à des révélations
antérieures je sois juste souligner que
du point de vue de l'administration
ces révélations lors pour l'instant nous
on n'a accès qu'à ce que la presse a
publié il n'y a pas de données je
croyais pas de bases de données en ligne
et par principe les journalistes ne
veulent pas donner aux administrations
fiscales plus d'informations au nom de
leurs principes déontologiques
donc pour nour en fait c'est c'est le
début d'un long chemin parce que donc on
a des informations qui sont assez assez
fragmentaire sur des personnes qui
détiendraient des sociétés à l'étranger
alors personnes qui sont ou non
résidente fiscale française parce que
finalement vous fait vous savez bien
qu'il suffit pas d'être français pour
être assujettis à l'impôt en france donc
il ya des personnalités qui ont été
cités qui sont non résidente depuis
depuis plusieurs années et pour lesquels
l'administration fiscale française est
pas en mesure
d'opérer des vérifications particulière
donc hormis le cas où les personnes dont
les noms sont cités viendrai
spontanément
régulariser leur situation et nous
donner des informations c'est pour nous
le début d'un long travail
pour
retrouvez les informations qui
permettent d'effectuer des redressements
ce qu'il suffit pas de savoir qu'une
personne détient une société dans tel ou
tel paradis fiscal pour en tirer des
conclusions opérationnelles sur le
montant des impôts qu'elle doit payer et
donc le plus souvent et sa difficulté à
laquelle on a été confronté lors des
précédents précédentes révélations c'est
qu'on a le nom du siège d'une société
mais sans information sur le lieu de
situation des comptes et encore moins
sur les sommes qui sont sur ces comptes
ou sur les années concernées ainsi peut
aussi y avoir des sujets de prescription
donc là tous la paudèze c'est un travail
qui est long et minutieux qui nous
conduit à faire d assistance
administrative internationale
auprès des pays concernés alors c'est un
bon test aussi un pour voir la bonne
volonté de ces pays dans la promptitude
et la qualité de leurs réponses mais
certains pays nous dise pas oui on vous
confirme que monsieur ou madame at elle
a bien une société chez nous mais on n'a
aucune information comptable et
financière et donc il faut chercher le
pays où sont les comptes pour poursuivre
nos procédures donc voilà c'est toute la
difficulté du sujet donc sur les panama
peppers ont en un peu de recul
[Musique]
et
donc on a des procédures qui ont abouti
on travaille de plus en plus avec la
justice donc il ya des actions
coordonnées certaines jetons les panama
peppers était piloté par le parquet
national financiers et donc tous les
services de l'état conjuguent leurs
efforts pour essayer d'avoir de
l'information et je le redis au delà du
des informations publiées
le chemin est très long pour avoir
toutes les informations pertinentes
permettant de faire les rectifications
fiscales nécessaires
donc voilà ce que je voulais dire je
voudrais aussi insister comme dans ces
sujets sur le rôle des intermédiaires
financiers
je regarde l'avant devenir un rapport de
l'osce et des
cas moins d'un an assure en finir avec
les montages financiers abusif réprimer
les intermédiaires qui favorise délits
fiscaux et la criminalité en col blanc
je crois qu'il ya un vrai sujet sur le
positionnement et les obligations de
certains intermédiaires
et donc ce sans faire de raccourci trop
trop saisissant
vous savez qu'on armé en ce moment même
le débat sur l'étendue du secret
professionnel
des avocats y compris dans leurs
fonctions de conseil et c'est quand même
un sujet qui nous interroge parce qu'il
faut qu'on ait la capacité d'aller
chercher des informations et si on se
crée des sanctuaires y compris en france
notre action sera encore plus limité
voilà donc sur l'ailé précédente vague
de révélations on a des résultats
directeur général communique et donc je
me sens autorisé à le faire kia soul et
panama peppers en avait 115 dossiers qui
ont conduit à 167 millions d'euros de
droits et de pénalités
sur les paradise peppers ou des
informations des plus fragmentaire on
est à ce jour à 11 millions d'euros de
droits et de pénalités
mais sur ces deux vagues précédentes
les travaux ne sont pas sont loin d'être
achevés donc ce sont des chiffres qu on
actualise au fur et à mesure donc voilà
ce que je voulais dire en introduction
sur notre état d'esprit la manière de
travailler
donc je peux assurer bien sûr de notre
détermination à combattre ces phénomènes
ça fait partie de notre travail et
on a beaucoup travaillé sur les vagues
précédentes nous allons travailler bien
sûr sur ces informations à condition
qu'elles soient un peu précises
merci monsieur jeune fille je me tourne
maintenant vers monsieur marc borhnauser
qui pourra nous faire part de son regard
d'avocats spécialisé en droit fiscal
patrimonial sur le recours à de tels
montages et leur nature juridique et
peut-être il pourra également peut-être
pas de position un petit peu sur le
secret et quand tour la profession
d'avocat et nous donner sa position cela
permettra d'avoir un peu d'interactions
ou d'interactivité entre nous oui je
remercie fait d'un keanu chin avoir
tendu la perche sur le le rôle des
avocats qui ne sont pas des
intermédiaires financiers comme les
autres en tout cas je tiens à le
rappeler mais je dois d'abord commencé
par dire que c'est c'est paradise
peppers je me demande comment ils vont
faire pour trouver un nouveau nom à
prévoir
à part dont il parlait pour les pandores
ap perth donc qui commence par un p
après panama après paradise avec quel va
être le prochain nom bon qui nous
apprennent pas grand chose sur les
techniques utilisées ni lait ni les
juridictions concernées les îles vierges
britanniques le panama la suisse je
dirais c'est toujours les mêmes usual
suspects
mais bon il faut quand même rappeler moi
je me suis plongé dans ce que les
journalistes ont bien voulu dévoiler
et tous tous ces schémas ne sont pas
nécessairement frauduleux il faut quand
même bien distinguer que lie à la fraude
la côte est qui est sanctionnable pour
lequel l'administration fiscale est là
et use de tous les moyens prévus par la
loi pour la réprimer et l'optimisation
qui dans notre société de liberté reste
encore un droit même si le mot fait
tâche maintenant on même nous on évite
de l'utiliser mais il n'en demeure pas
moins que quel soit agressive ou pas
agressive elle est soit du bon côté de
la loi soit du mauvais côté de la loi et
il ya quand même des marqueurs objectifs
qui permettent de de la cerner et la
classe et
ensuite il faut distinguer
les problématiques de fiscalité et les
problématiques de confidentialité je
pense qu'on ne peut pas retirer aux gens
le souhait de rester discret sur leur
investissement pour autant évidemment
que l'argent qu'ils investissent soit de
l'argent qui n'est pas sale ou teintés
avec quand même effectivement on peut
dire une réserve sur les personnalités
exposées publiquement un politiquement
les fameuses pubs qui l ont un devoir
évidemment plus lourd que le commun des
mortels quant à la transparence de son
patrimoine moi j'ai quand même été
frappé qu'un homme comme tony blair
possède enfin il est acquis un tel
patrimoine fin cette fois même ça pose
question
même si je ne lui fais pas de procès
d'intention enfin c'est une cinquantaine
de maisons au royaume uni face et c'est
quand même des grosses sommes
et puis je voudrais également précisé le
rôle des avocats qui ne sont pas des
intermédiaires financiers nous les
avocats nous avons une déontologie très
strictes
nous ne pouvons pas participer à la
commission d'une infraction et si nous
le faisons de toute façon nous ne sommes
pas protégés par le secret professionnel
le secret professionnel c'est le profit
le secret professionnel de nos clients
et c'est dans leur intérêt que la loi
nous nous la donner donc nous ne sommes
pas des intermédiaires financiers comme
les autres et le
législateur n'a rien à gagner à nous
prendre pour cible pour réprimer une
fraude qui peut parfaitement être
réprimés autrement sans aller nous nous
perquisitionné dans nos cabinets parce
que nous attaquer s'est aussi attaqué la
justice et s'est attaqué le consentement
à l'impôt nous avocats nous ce nous
participons
à l'expression de cette justice qui pour
trouve aboutir à une décision doit
entendre non seulement l'accusation mais
également la défense et cette
distinction entre le conseil et la
défense sur laquelle le sénat s'est
prononcé récemment est une distinction
qui n'existe pas en tout cas pas dans
les textes européens qui ont une norme
une autorité supérieure à la loi
française et je pense à la convention
européenne des droits de l'homme en
particulier et sa jurisprudence qui ne
distingue pas le secret de l'avocat dans
son exercice de conseils de celui de sa
mission de défense il est indispensable
que nos clients puissent nous parler
sans craindre qu'on puisse les dénoncer
d'une manière ou d'une autre
alors la suite de ces pentes de rappers
est ce que une fois de plus ils vont
justifier une loi de circonstance qui va
encore donner encore plus de pouvoir
l'administration fiscale pour réprimer
la fraude moi je tiens quand même à
rappeler deux choses la première c'est
que les textes existent en l'espace des
dix dernières années l'arsenal juridique
pénale de l'administration fiscale s'est
considérablement renforcée à tel point
que les limites sont probablement
atteinte déjà je vous rappelle que pas
plus tard qu après demain le conseil
constitutionnel va statuer sur la
compatibilité avec la constitution de la
procédure elle 23 c du livre des
procédures fiscales
755 du code général des impôts est
peut-être qu'il a validé le texte
peut-être qu'il va le déclarer
inconstitutionnelle peut-être il va
mettre des réserves d'interprétation
mais une chose est sûre c'est que il va
être difficile d'aller plus loin que ce
mécanisme qui permet à l'administration
fiscale je le rappelle d'interroger
quelqu'un qui n'a pas satisfait ses
obligations déclaratives de déclaration
des comptes étrangers pour lui demander
d'où vient son patrimoine et s'il ne
peut pas donner de réponse satisfaisante
de le taxer de taxer le conte le solde
du compte bancaire l'année la plus
élevée le solde le plus élevé pardon du
compte bancaire au titre des 10
dernières années aux droits de mutation
à titre gratuit aux tarifs non par an
c'est-à-dire de 60%
là peut-être que nous arrivons à la
limite de l'exercice consistant à
renforcer systématiquement les pouvoirs
de l'administration fiscale et puis la
deuxième chose et dernière pour cette
conclusion introduction par donc je
voulais dire c'est que l'administration
fiscale s'est énormément renforcé en
termes de savoir faire ces dix dernières
années je vous livre une petite anecdote
qui qui concerne la première cellule
woerth savez pour régulariser les gens
qui étaient sur la liste la fameuse lisa
chez hsbc moi j'avais un dossier aucune
action qui n'était pas sur cette liste
mais qui s'était laissée embringuer
embarqué à acheter les titres d'une
beady eye qui portait un investissement
qu'il voulait faire et que le vendeur
avait manifestement loger là parce que
l'argent qu'il avait mis était pas
forcément très clair et mais mon client
lui voulait faire cet investissement
le seul moyen c'est ed racheter les
titres labit vieille
comme il savait que c'était pas très
bien il n'en avait pas parlé à son
conseil l'occurrence mois il avait fait
ça dans son coin avec une banque suisse
et puis quand il m'a dit ça j'ai dit il
faut aller directement profité de la
cellule woerth et je me souviens d'être
d'avoir était en entretien reçus par le
directeur chargé de cette cellule
monsieur bignon de mémoire et quand j'ai
commencé à lui expliqué chez marni
zoryan viviane marghadi m'a dit c'est
quoi une ville aille en 1989 celle parce
que c'était convivial et bien je peux
vous dire que ça a changé
l'administration fiscale a
considérablement renforcé son expertise
grâce aux campagnes de régularisation
qui lui ont permis finalement de voir
l'autre côté des opérations puisque les
conseils sont venus expliquer ce qu'ils
avaient fait pour les régulariser ils
ont acquis une connaissance de la
pratique très très très haut niveau et
aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui nous avons une
administration bien formés qui connaît
bien ces techniques et qui peut ainsi
tout à fait réprimer les schémas qui
aurait été abusifs ce qui n'est pas je
le rappelle le cas de tous les schémas
dénoncée par les
pandora paper je vous remercie
si beaucoup je me permets de vous
relancer nous avons un peu d'avancé
vous avez dit concernant l'optimisation
il ya des facteurs objectifs je pourrais
en reparler vous pourriez nous lier un
quels sont les facteurs objectifs entre
la fraude et l'optimisation c'est par
exemple si vous ne respectez pas la loi
vous êtes dans la fraude si vous la
voyez si vous les respectez vous êtes à
priori dans l'optimisation après il ya
aussi la de l'abus de droit et donc si
vous ne respectez pas si vous respectez
la loi mais pas son esprit vous êtes
également dans la fraude mais tout ça
via la jurisprudence on a quand même la
capacité en tout cas nous avocats de
guider nos clients pour l'heure les
accompagner là où ils doivent se trouver
c'est-à-dire du bon côté de la ligne
merci de ces de ces précisions donc je
me tourne maintenant vers madame julia
alibrandi peut-être enfin que nous livre
son analyse économique du recours à ces
structures et des conséquences pour les
finances publiques c'est le veut bien
vous rapprocherez également le micro
je suppose
on va le voir
alors monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs je voudrais
commencer tenté par ne mangeait pas mais
n'hésitez pas à leur apogée ok
donc je vous remercie au nom de
l'observatoire européen de la fiscalité
pour cette invitation on est très
heureux d'être là avec vous pour
discuter de ces problématiques donc
quand vous l'avez l'a rappelé monsieur
le président en il ya quelques la
semaine dernière on a eu la révélation
de peindre apple ce qui montre comment
aujourd'hui il ya des schémas qui permet
de cacher des
importantes sommes de patrimoine et
d'éviter
du coup l'imposition sur ces semble donc
les pandas gaiters nous montre une
partie de ces phénomènes et la recherche
économique essaye de donner une taille
plus globale à tout le patrimoine
financier qui est détenu offshore donc
par exemple pour l'europe on estime que
1500 milliards d'euros donc l'équivalent
de 10% du pib sont gardés offshore et la
perte des recettes fiscales engendrées
par
par ce phénomène est d'environ 46
milliards d'euros sur les gars pour
graduellement le cas de la france on a
un patrimoine financier de tenues en
short environ 300 milliards d'euros ce
qui engendre une perte de recettes
d'environ 10 milliards d'euros
donc au delà de ce chiffre agrégé c'est
très important de rappeler un phénomène
important que
ce patrimoine et surtout détenus par les
individus les plus riches de de notre
société
donc ce manque d'information empêche
au gouvernement de pouvoir mener des
politiques de redistribution et
financières efficaces et qui sont
adéquates à la distribution des
richesses qu'on voit dans la population
donc jusqu'à maintenant évidemment comme
vous l'avez raclée des mesures qui ont
été prises pour combler ce manque
d'informations et notamment l'échangé
d'informations automatique
relatifs aux comptes bancaires et
financières donc ça c'était une avancée
majeure
surtout pour le fait que c'est
automatique et parce qu'il ya un grand
nombre de pays qui participent et enfin
très important à souligner c'est que les
états unis l'ont pas aux relations
réciproques avec les autres pays donc la
france par exemple ne reçoit pas les
informations de citoyens français qui
ont des comptes bancaires aux états unis
et surtout après les révélations de pont
de la paix interne soient les activités
aux états unis ça c'est un point qui
semble être très important
en plus de ça il ya aussi le registre de
bénéficier avec un effectif qui est en
train d'être instaurées dans plusieurs
pays
et
et ça ça avance
un peu doucement mais il ya de plus en
plus de pays qui adhèrent à cette
initiative mais le progrès il reste sur
toulon dans les émissions le plus opaque
dont les juridictions dont on aurait
besoin de plus d'information qui manque
cruellement aux administrations comme il
nous a rappelé monsieur duty
donc en plus de ces mesures qui sont
déjà en place
un observatoire on suggère des mesures
supplémentaires qui pourraient aider à
continuer
à combattre la fraude et l'évasion
fiscale donc premièrement on suggère de
créer un cadastre financiers pour lutter
contre l'opacité qui entoure la richesse
mondiale ces répartitions donc ces
outils il pourrait donner au
gouvernement ou vision globale des
richesses détenues par ces citoyens et
donc mener des politiques fiscales et
deyris tribution cohérent avec la réelle
distribution des richesses
des ces contribuables et ensuite
on veut rappeler comme il a déjà fait
monsieur ian aussi que les
professionnels qui choisi de favoriser
la fraude fiscale et les flux financiers
illicites ils en sont responsables
comme leurs clients et et donc on en
souhaite que la mise en place des
sanctions plus sévères pour ces
fournisseurs de services qui sont
destinés à la fraude fiscale et qui
porte donc une préjudice à la société
merci
madame enfin je me tourne vers monsieur
quentin marinello est donc responsable
plaidoyer justice fiscale et inégalités
pour femmes france
peut-être pourra-t-il nous indiquer s'il
y a des spécificités des pentes droit à
people ou est ce que ce sont des
informations par mille autres qu'on a
déjà eu et qu'il n'y a finalement rien
de nouveau il y at-il donc les
spécificités par rapport aux précédents
travaux d'investigation
merci marinello et merci pour cette
invitation monsieur le président
mesdames messieurs les sénateurs et
sénatrices pour répondre directement à
votre question oui il ya des
spécificités à cette investigation la
première est la plus grande à mon sens
c'est que cette fuite de données elle
couvre environ 15 ans jusqu'à une heure
très très récente et donc 14 les
dossiers de 14 intermédiaire financier
donc ce qu'on peut voir de manière assez
claire sait comment à la fois des
intermédiaires financiers et des
juridictions fiscales vont s'adapter aux
changements législatifs ont chacun
s'adapter aux changements législatifs
notamment en matière fiscale de certains
pays notamment les sanctions mises en
place par l'union européenne autour de
sa liste de paradis fiscaux et comment
on voit certains contribuables qui était
dans certains paradis fiscaux monsieur
ben cheikh vous parlais tout à l'heure
des illusions ce stade est que commencer
personne n'a finalement vont dans des
territoires qu'on n'aurait pas forcément
soupçonné au premier abord d'être des
paradis fiscaux on a vu notamment
l'émergence de deux territoires comme le
dakota du sud aux états unis qui font
pas partie du ruisseau spex pour les
personnes qui ne connaissent pas
forcément le droit fiscal comme étant
des territoires où on peut loger des
actifs dans tout en toute discrétion
donc ça je pense que c'est le ces le
l'aspect le plus le plus intéressant de
cette fuite c'est vraiment de montrer au
cours des années comment certains
acteurs se sont adaptées au changement
de législation et c'est utile pour nous
y compris pour montrer les limites de
notre action de l'action publique
jusqu'à maintenant est comment
et c'est bien normal et ce qui a frappé
notamment c'est le nombre de personnes
en responsabilité et ça me nourrit le
finalement une espèce de méfiance envers
envers l'action de poules politique ça
ça sape le consentement à l'impôt et moi
c'est vraiment sur cet aspect là que je
voudrais vous interpellez c'est vraiment
sur comment on retrouve une confiance en
l'action politique comment on retrouve
le consentement à l'impôt comment ne
remplace les outils pour montrer que
l'action politique lutte vraiment contre
la fraude l'évasion fiscale est pas que
parce que évidemment dans le cadre de
cette investigation on a vu des faits
en tout cas des faits reprochés qui
devront être caractérisée de blanchiment
potentiel d'argent y compris deux
sources qui pourraient être liés à la
mafia italienne au terrorisme aux
narcotrafiquants
expert externe et donc le le message que
je veux faire passer aujourd'hui c'est
l'importance notamment de la
transparence la transparence pas
simplement dans les échanges
d'informations entre les administrations
fiscales mais auprès des citoyennes et
des citoyens
monsieur yann nouchy parlé tout à
l'heure de des limites d'information en
termes de sociétés écran il ya 70% des
affaires de corruption qui implique une
société écran aujourd'hui 70% quels sont
les outils pour faire face à ça en
france on a donc un échange automatique
d'informations on à l'identification des
bénéficiaires effectifs et depuis peu
depuis quelques mois on a un registre
des sociétés qui permet d'identifier les
bénéficiaires effectifs donc qui
derrière une société possède
effectivement cette société ce registre
en termes d'accès au public je me place
encore une fois même en termes d'accès
au public par en termes d'accès à
l'information pour l'administration il a
certaines limites la première c'est
qu'on sait registre qui est disponible
uniquement sur un accès à la pièce donc
il faut qu'on aille chercher
l'information une par une la deuxième
c'est que l'on n'est pas encore sûr
aujourd'hui de son taux de complétude
les dernières données publiques paraître
75% il y avait notamment des problèmes
au niveau des dsi selon des travaux des
années ci ont notamment été menées par
transparence international qui aura eu
toute sa place d'ailleurs à 7 à cette
table roulement là dessus
tout l'enjeu c'est notamment de se dire
qu'il suffit pas de publier ces
informations faut pour aller vérifier et
la qualité mais ces données peut
fortement interrogé peut forcément jouer
sur la question de la confiance en
l'action publique je vous donne deux
exemples qui a été révélée après open
luxe dans registre des sociétés du
luxembourg il y avait 50% donc la moitié
des entreprises qui ne déclaraient aucun
bénéficiaire effectif dans celui du
royaume-uni oui ou pour le coup c'est il
n'est pas accessible que à la pièce mais
on est capable d'extraire à les données
et de les de les analyser on avait des
dizaines de milliers d'entreprises qui
n'avaient pas de bénéficiaires effectifs
déclaré on avait des entreprises qui
avaient parfois un bénéficiaire effectif
qui possédait 100 150 200 entreprises et
on voit bien que c'est c'est un drapeau
rouge comme on dit sur les prête noms
autre cas et on avait également des fois
des données assez fantaisiste de
bénéficiaires effectifs qui avait trois
ans quatre ans alors on peut
s'interroger sur l'utilité de de faire
transférer en patrimoine extrêmement tôt
mais enfin pour pour jouer sur
l'héritage mais je pense que ça il
s'agissait moins que ça plutôt que soit
l'information erronée ou manifestement
manifestement fausses
néanmoins la plus grande limite
aujourd'hui sur le registre des
bénéficiaires effectifs c'est que dès
que vous avez le des registres publics
dès que vous avez besoin d'avoir accès
dans un montage à une structure qui est
hors de france vous ne l'avez pas serre
que je suis contribuables français je
possède une entreprise mais il n'est pas
situé en france je n'apparaîtrait pas
dans le registre des bénéficiaires
effectifs et donc renforcer ce registre
c'est notamment prendre croisé
l'ensemble des données qui sont
disponibles publiquement et c'est
finalement un premier pas vers le
cadastre financier que
malama lyprendi appelé de ses voeux il
ya il ya quelques quelques minutes c'est
finalement croisé l'ensemble des données
permettre à des citoyens d'avoir un
droit de regard sur
les structures les montages fiscaux qui
sont utilisés par ces contribuables y
compris quand ils ont des actifs hors de
france la limite par rapport à ça
évidemment c'est qu'on n'a pas accès à
tout un nombre d'actifs qui sont logés
dans des territoires qu'on appelle des
paradis fiscaux et là dessus et je vais
terminer là dessus rapidement pour
laisser la parole
c'est tout l'enjeu est l'utilité d'une
liste de paradis fiscaux on pourra faire
pression sur des pays tiers on a une
liste de paradis fiscaux au niveau
français qui est essentiellement basé
sur la culture est question de
coopération fiscale et on intègre les
pays de la liste de l'union européenne
alice de l'union européenne jusqu'à
présent elle est essentiellement axée
sur la coopération fiscale et pratiques
fiscales dommageables mais y'a pas cette
question de la transparence par exemple
on ne juge pas que si un pays n'a pas de
registre public des bénéficiaires
effectifs ça pose un problème et c'est
et il pourrait être mis sur une liste
par exemple une liste grise est donc
tout l'enjeu aujourd'hui c'est dire
comment on fait pression sur ces pays
tiers et la liste des paradis fiscaux
européenne approuvée dans une certaine
mesure son utilité à faire pression sur
les pays tiers quand elles n'étaient pas
soumises à des pressions politiques et
lorsque ces critères étaient objectif
est ambitieux enfin juste un dernier mot
sur les intermédiaires financiers je
suis absolument d'accord avec ce qui a
été dit par
les deux intervenants en face de moi il
faut absolument renforcer
aujourd'hui le contrôle sur les
intermédiaires financiers il ya certains
intermédiaires financiers qui
aujourd'hui ne sont pas couverts par les
obligations de lutte contre le
blanchiment et donc qu'ils n'ont pas à
faire ce travail ce qu'on appelle le
newcastle pour pour savoir d'où vient
d'où vient l'argent et on peut
travailler sur sur des textes pour
améliorer ça il ya aussi tout un
problème de reportive puisqu'aujourd'hui
la mule tra majorité des cas de
blanchiment d'argent un clic des
personnes morales mais les déclarations
à trac fin c'est essentiellement des
personnes physiques donc on voit qu'il
n'a pas forcément les informations sur
sur le gros du problème et puis enfin
évidemment en force et renforcer les
sanctions voilà je m'arrête là merci
beaucoup
merci monsieur parrinello merci à vous
tous nous allons démarrer par le
rapporteur général du budget bien tandem
pardon oui merci merci monsieur le
président est d'abord je veux remercier
les quatre intervenants à la fois pour
la clarté de leurs expressions et je
dirais même leur concision
je vais aborder
peut-être directement à travers
3 3 questions
claude raynal le président a rappelé
dans son propos introductif
le pr le projet baisse de l' ocde
comporte lui un certain nombre de
recommandations pour renforcer les
règles de fiscalité des sociétés
étrangères contrôler il ya une directive
effectivement atteinte de 2016 qui
comprend différentes dispositions pour
renforcer le contrôle de ces entités en
permettant par exemple d'imposer des
revenus issus d'une société localisée
dans un territoire à faible imposition
pourtant il n'a pas été jusqu'à présent
jugé utile d'adapter le dispositif
existant en france à l'article 209 b de
notre code général des impôts malgré ces
avancées
qu'elles en sont peut-être de la vie de
chacun d'entre vous les raisons et en
quoi cet outil permet d'y et il permet
tilt ou non d'ailleurs de lutter
efficacement contre de tels montages
financiers
deuxième deuxième question les
intermédiaires financiers dans le cadre
est effectivement de la directive dite
d'axis sont tenus de déclarer à
l'administration fiscale les montages
fiscaux considérés comme agressif qu'il
conservait commercialisait les données
sont ensuite échangées entre les états
membres quel bilan peut-on pouvez vous
tirer de cette obligation est est ce
qu'on pourrait imaginer qu'une telle
obligation
je lirai se mettre en place pour être la
norme au niveau international et puis
peut-être
il ya eu un début de réponse mais dans
l'intervention de monsieur parrinello
sur la transparence jeu revenir sur les
échanges d'informations entre les
administrations fiscales qui joue un
rôle essentiel en matière de lutte
contre les pratiques fiscales
dommageables le forum mondial a mis en
place des procédures standardisées
pourtant les pandora paper l'indiquent
ces échanges manifestement ne suffisent
pas que ce soit d'ailleurs du fait des
territoires participants ou du périmètre
des informations couvertes
quel est donc d'après vous alors je vois
je regarde plutôt monsieur iannucci mais
pas seulement le rôle de ces données
pour le contrôle fiscal et
quelles sont les limites que vous
identifier dans ce dispositif et comment
pourrait-on et remédier
merci mais c'est la porte en général
alors compte tenu des délais et de la
formation que nous avons ce matin je
vous propose de garder chacune des
questions du rapporteur général à
l'esprit pour pouvoir répondre tout à
l'heure et je vais compléter par des
questions de nos collègues
sa chambre et je vous l'indiquais
également que nous ferons ensuite nous
donnerons la parole pour une brève
réponse en fonction des thèmes parmi les
questions qui vous paraissent relever de
votre compétence et de vos connaissances
et que nous le ferons dans l'ordre
inverse c'est à dire que nous
commencerons pas monsieur parrinello et
nous finirons par monsieur inutile
donc je vais donner la parole tout de
suite si vous le voulez bien à éric
bocquet qui sera suivie de sophie
talipot liant éric bocquet
oui merci monsieur le président d'abord
je voudrais saluer l'initiative
excellente de la commission des finances
qui a réussi d'un délai effectivement
très court huit jours après la
révélation des pentes de la pelleteuse
cette table ronde forte intéressante
forte utile qui me conforte dans l'idée
que c'est un sujet dont il faut parler
régulièrement et pas seulement dans
l'émotion des révélations
effectuée par la presse salue à la
presse entre parenthèses de mener ce
travail depuis de longues années le
consortium est un essai les gens les
investigations mène un travail
remarquable mais depuis la sphère
cahuzac en 2013 je me suis amusé à
compter le nombre d'affaires je pense
qu'on en est au 13e dossier de
révélations fracassantes je vais pas les
énumérer vous les connaissez aussi bien
que moi donc tout révélatrice de ces
pratiques incroyable et scandaleuse du
monde de l'off shore en tout est connu
aujourd'hui on ne peut plus s'étonner
des informations qu'on a mais nous
sidère encore à chaque fois la même
sidération le même le même scandale ça a
été rappelé les révélations d'open luxe
au mois de février dernier le journal le
monde devait mener une enquête au long
cours deux chiffres 55 mille sociétés
off shore au luxembourg
détenant ensemble 6500 milliards
d'actifs nous qui travaillons ici sur le
budget de la france qui est péniblement
à 400 milliards de dépenses face à nous
ramène à une échelle absolument
incroyable les pandora paper jose 1300
milliards de dollars ça fait dix mille
milliards d'euros voilà je vais pas plus
loin autant d'argent qui échappent à
l'impôt bien sûr
à l'occasion des panamas papers en 2016
c'est le cabinet maussac fonseka qui
avait été pointée mais on se rend compte
avec ces nouvelles révélations que ce
cabinet maussac fonséca n'était pas un
cas isolé mais a fait école et à de
nombreux concurrents de par le monde
cette année on nous parle du cabinet
baker mckenzie 5000 avocats présents
dans 46 pays du monde mackenzie au
connaît ils se sont occupés d'autres
affaires en france il ya quelques temps
au mode la pandémie
14 cabinets sont cités dans ces
révélations dé pandora paper
créateur donc de sociétés offshore
c'était anonyme offshore évidemment le
but c'est d'échapper à l'impôt c'est de
bénéficier d'une totale opacité et
d'échapper aussi aux juges et aux lois
des personnalités politiques sont cités
ça fait beaucoup de mal bien évidemment
à la république a la confiance de nos
concitoyens
s'ils sont nos concitoyens sont cités
dans ces dans ces documents
dans ses révélations on apprend à lire
des cours et on a la confirmation que
des états membres de l'union européenne
sont eux-mêmes addict de ces pratiques
régulières on a cité le luxembourg au
mois de février dernier dans la sphère
open ux et cette fois ci c'est chypre
dont il est question à ma connaissance
ces deux états sont membres de l'union
européenne ce n'est pas sans poser de
problèmes politiques de fond auquel il
faudrait s'attaquer alors ces dossiers
illustrent parfaitement le caractère
systémique de ces industries de
l'offshore on n'est pas dans un
dysfonctionnement d'une économie
libéralisée mondialisé dérégulé non
c'est au coeur du système il faut des
clients il faut les territoires
complaisant il faut des banquiers oui il
faut des avocats des cabinets des
notaires des prestataires des prête noms
des sociétés écrans et caetera et c est
tout cela fait système et tout cela
organise l'opacité
alors j'ai quelques questions à
soumettre à nos invités aujourd'hui
tout d'abord monsieur iannucci donc sur
les 600 français qui ont dit qu'ils sont
cités vous avez évoqué tout à l'heure
comment vous traitiez ce genre de sujet
mais est ce que vous pourriez préciser
la stratégie qui est la vôtre de quels
moyens disposez vous parce que là les
journalistes nous ont rappelé qu'ils
avaient exploité 12 millions de
documents j'imagine la masse de travail
humain qu'il faut pour exploiter ces
données alors je sais que monsieur
darmana en 2018 avait créé une police
fiscale de 25 individus sans doute très
compétent mais c'est 25 et dans le même
temps depuis vingt ans la dgesip a perdu
38 mille emplois ça n'est pas non plus
sans conséquence monsieur ministre du
sob la semaine asnières disait qu'après
les panama papers nous avions récupéré
200 millions d'euros venu en sait un peu
je crois avoir noté que vous parliez de
176 millions d'euros là aussi le
décalage est assez saisissant entre ces
chiffres récupérer et ceux qui sont
censés nous nous échapper ensuite
deuxième point jour évoquées c'est la
chaîne de responsabilités effectivement
dans la commission denquête que nous
avions mené en 2013 ici on peut pas
s'évader sans un peu des deux évidemment
et je me souviens d'une intervention
d'un d'une personnalité qu'on avait
auditionné monsieur marc roche à
l'époque rejoint liste pour le monde
correspondant à londres fin connaisseur
de la city et du monde de la finance et
de ses acteurs il avait dit je cite les
banques ne sont qu'un petit élément d'un
réseau de complicités plus vaste dans
laquelle on trouve des bureaux d'avocats
des cabinets comptables des conseillers
financiers alors évidemment on entend
sur cet argument qui consiste à dire
optimisation évasion mais je rappellerai
cette citation fameuse d'initier les qui
était le chancelier de l'échiquier
gouvernement britannique entre 74 et 79
et il a eu ce mot un jour la différence
entre une optimisation et l'évasion
fiscale est dans l'épaisseur l'épaisseur
du mur d'une prison voilà chacun en
pensera ce qu'il veut mais j'ai trouvé
ça assez drôle troisième point qui a été
évoqué dans le chai parrinello c'est la
liste des paradis fiscaux en europe
aux yeux de l'union européenne aucun
état membre ne peut être considéré par
le par la commission comme un paradis
fiscal or là on a deux pays majeurs
luxembourg notamment mais je pense
également à chapron peu à chypre pardo
on pourrait citer malte on pourrait
s'intéresser ou pas yves aux pays bas
avec des sièges des holdings l'irlande
un statut fiscal un peu particulier
aussi or pour l'union européenne non
voilà pas de paradis fiscal au sein de
l'union européenne je pense que là il ya
déjà un deuxième trou dans le bouclier
plus les complicités que malheureusement
on constate on a cité tony blair en à
citer dsk tout ça est absolument
dommageable fondamentalement dommageable
et il faudrait qu'on s'intéresse de près
à ces sujets merci
puis un merci eric alors éric bocquet je
vous le dis et méchas collègues à
bénéficier d'un tarif de faveur si je
puis dire
compte tenu de cette thématique dans son
travail parlementaire et donc je vais
ramener les autres aux deux minutes
réglementaires en commençant en le
remerciant par sophie palliez polluants
président je vous remercie mais je
réclame l'égalité
c'est un combat que nous partageons tous
bien non mais je vais essayer d'être
plus rapide car éric bocquet a dit
beaucoup de choses que je partage merci
à la commission ça c'est une première
chose merci à la presse bien entendu
sans les règles sans laquelle
aujourd'hui nous n'aurions pas
d'information et pas de capacité
d'action et c'est quand même une
question qu'on doit se poser merci aussi
aux lanceurs d'alert qui prennent
beaucoup de risques et qui sont encore
aujourd'hui je le crois peut pas assez
protégé c'est une question que je pose
notamment
les ong oxfam parce qu'il ya peut-être
là aussi des choses à faire
plusieurs une remarque et puis des
questions
monsieur bur know there ou parliez
d'optimisation en dix ans après tous ces
endroits
tant que c'est pas illégal moi j'observe
jusqu'à la semaine dernière pour
justifier la réforme de l'assurance
chômage on pointait
les précaires en disant mais optimise
c'est scandaleux c'est scandaleux et là
c'est normal voyez donc il ya un petit
peu ce deux poids deux mesures dans le
discours point de pas votre discours en
particulier mais le discours général et
je crois que là il ya quand même un
problème extrêmement fort et qui touche
je crois à la capacité effectivement de
faire société car il ya certains
certaines qui s'extrait de leurs
obligations de leur rôle comme tout le
monde de participer à l'effort public
pour faire société il ya quand même là
on le voit un état de violence dans
notre société un de certains qui
s'autorise tout cela est aujourd'hui où
cela était notée 4 millions de nouveau
vulnérable dans notre pays je voulais
juste noté cela on a beaucoup débattu en
2018 notamment autour de la loi
présentée par monsieur darmanin monsieur
du soft la société de confiance nous
avions à l'époque
et je m'en souviens très bien posé un
certain nombre d'amendements sur
notamment
la question du fait de réprimer les
intermédiaires donc ça a été rejetée à
l'époque donc je vois que peut-être que
en réalité l'administration fiscale
trouverait que c'est une bonne chose
aussi une des propositions pour inverser
la charge de la preuve sert qu'à partir
du moment où on voit qu'il ya une
société qui qui qui arrive on sait pas
trop pourquoi hop ce n'est plus à
l'administration fiscale de démontrer
qu'il y a montage problématique mais
cette à la personne qui a fait le
montage de justifier pourquoi il avait
pris ce chemin là un ski je pense aussi
serait une source de facilitation pour
l'administration fiscale donc je pose
aussi cette question terme de quoi faire
et comment faire pour avancer puisque on
le voit la loi de 2018 qui devait régler
tous les problèmes ne l'a pas du tout
régler et on sait aussi nous n'avons
cessé de dénoncer il ya certes une
augmentation des moyens notamment
techniques avec le data mining dont nous
nous a beaucoup parlé pour faire en
sorte que les administrations fiscales
et davantage de moyens techniques pour
aller au bon endroit mais nous n'avions
non plus pas cessé de dénoncer le fait
que et bien finalement quand on regarde
le nombre d' enquêtes menées elles sont
toujours d'un même nombre c'est à dire
qu'en fait on ne cherche pas à avoir un
service public qui correspondent aux
besoins c'est à dire au nombre de gens
qui fraudent mais on se dit bah on a on
peut faire tant d' enquête on va se
contenter de ça et on voit quand même
dernière question qu'il ya une baisse du
montant récupéré par l'état alors même
qu on observe que finalement comme cela
a été dit à chaque nouvelle loi cette
industrie tellement inventis qui
innovent sans arrêt elle trouve de
nouveaux moyens pour certains et
certaines de s'extraire de leur
obligation de solidarité et de justice
merci sophie avé mort et puis didier
rambaud
merci monsieur le président c'est à être
encore plus court sims y évoquer le
nombre de dossiers qui avaient pu être
récupérés au plus tôt de somme qu'ils
aient pu être ré couvre recouvrer dans
le cadre des précédentes affaires je
crois qu'il a indiqué ce que ça pouvait
représenter en termes de pourcentage par
rapport à la masse globale tant en
nombre de dossiers 40 ans hommes et
jaurès à voir aussi s'il y a des
perspectives d'arriver à améliorer les
recouvrements sur ces scandales
précédent à la suite de tous ces
scandales froid un certain nombre de mes
collègues l'ont dit je crois que ce qui
est important c'est d'essayer de faire
en sorte que des mesures efficaces
soient soient prises sans pour autant
évidemment arriver dans des situations
où comme le suggère ma collègue ont
inversé la charge la prof ce qui est
peut-être quand même un petit peu un
petit peu fort mais concrètement je
m'adresse plus particulièrement au
prince dans l'administration fiscale
quels outils souhaiteriez vous
disposez que dont vous ne disposez pas
aujourd'hui pour être encore plus
efficace à la fois pour si possible
empêcher ce type de pratiques et ensuite
pour recouvrer les fonds concrètement
est-ce qu'il faut renforcer les
coopérations internationales que ce soit
dans le cadre européen ou autre est ce
qu'il faut comme ça a été dit par un
certain nombre de mes collègues et pas
un certain nombre d'intervenants prévoir
des sanctions des intermédiaires qui
ceux qui se prêtent et qui souvent même
un site à ce type d'action et puis
personne n'a osé le dire parce que c'est
toujours un sujet tabou quand on parle
de cette profession est-ce qu'il faut
que les journalistes eux-mêmes fasse un
peu propres de transparence et accepte
lorsqu'il ya vraiment des délits voire
des crimes avérés de d'être un petit peu
plus coopératif qui qui nous sont ça
semble être un sujet tabou de parler de
de ça et là au nom de la liberté de la
presse mais je je brise le tabou et je
pose la question
merci hervé didier rambaud puis batterie
c'est joli merci monsieur le président
de deux remarques très synthétique la
première j'ai retrouvé un article d'un
grand quotidien du soir qui date de
décembre 2018 et qui expliquait qu'il
était pratiquement impossible pour un
état seul comme la france de stopper
l'évasion fiscale je cite la phrase
modifié les règles pour forcer les
français les plus fortunés à payer leurs
impôts en france nécessiterait la
modification de conventions fiscales
internationales qui prévalent sur le
droit français aussi partagez vous ce
constat est est-ce envisageable
deuxième remarque c'est ce plus
optimistes c'est ce qui s'est passé la
semaine dernière au sein de l' ocde
puisque on peut se réjouir de voir plus
de 140 pays qui se sont mis d'accord sur
la fiscalité sur la taxation mondiale
des multinationales à plus de 2,1 à
hauteur de 2 15% même les derniers pays
opposant la hongrie l'irlande l'estonie
en lever et semble-t-il leurs objections
donc est ce qu'on pourrait considérer
que cet accord est prémonitoire et qui
pourrait nous permettre d'espérer
davantage de coopération dans la lutte
contre l'évasion fiscale je vous
remercie
merci didier patrice joly puis vanina
paolig agen merci monsieur le président
merci nos intervenants pour la diversité
de ses regrets portée et d'une certaine
manière croisée peut-être dire qu'il ya
urgence à agir du point de vue
démocratique c'est évident der sar cet
évangile consentons de l'impôt est en
jeu tribution des charges aux charges
collectives également et que cette
sécession des riches il faut bien
appeler ça ainsi
participe à la montée du populisme deux
choses parce que beaucoup ont été dites
pour insister sur un sur deux sur deux
points et peut-être les compléter tout
d'abord et on a il s'était dit il n'y a
aucune commune mesure entre les retours
que on a pu obtenir du point de vue de
avait qu'a pu obtenir l'administration
fiscale au regard des sommes qui sont en
jeu je dirais donc là on voit qu'il ya
un problème de moyens il ya d'autres
types de problème moi j'aimerais
éclairer sur ce sujet là comment se
fait-il qu'on n'est pas d'une certaine
manière plus productif en matière de
récupération du du
deuxième élément sur l'établissement et
l'actualisation des listes des paradis
fiscaux européens moi j'aimerais savoir
quelle est la vie de nos interlocuteurs
ici dans la mesure où on voit que
concomitamment effectivement à allah
l'émergence de ce scandale des panamas
dépens de ra peppers on s'aperçoit que
des des paradis fiscaux sont sortis de
la liste des paradis fiscaux identifié
comme tel par l'union européenne on ne
peut être que surpris merci
merci patrice vanina pas olivia jane
depuis michel canévet oui messieurs
président merci beaucoup d'avoir
organisé cette table-ronde merci à tous
les intervenants
j'avais une première question qui
concerne leur registre est bénéficiaire
effectif en tant que praticienne du
droit je sais que c'est très compliqué
déjà en droit français de modifier sur
infogreffe des régis de bénéficiaires
effectifs
ça fonctionne pas très bien en fait donc
c'est très difficile d'avoir un registre
à jour et je m'interroge en fait sur les
moyens qu'on pourrait mettre en oeuvre
pour rendre ces registres plus
opérationnelles déjà à titre général
c'est ce qui serait envisageable de
consolider un registre des bénéficiaires
effectifs au niveau de l'union
européenne voir via des traités à
l'échelon international
parce qu'on le sait c'est vraiment la
chaîne d'interposition et les
actionnariat en cascade qui qui nous
permettent de tracer en fait le cas
échéant ces
fraudes et puis enfin je partage tout ce
qui a été dit sur la liste des paradis
fiscaux en europe il faut vraiment qu'on
s'interroge sur certains de nos
partenaires est un membre qui ne semble
pas jouer tout à fait franc jeu avec
l'eau et cette question mérite mérite
d'être soulevée je pense merci veut
dynamique celle qu'avait depuis qu'eric
aux seuls présidents charlene je
voudrais remercier de nos intervenants
pour leur apport tout d'abord je
voudrais dire que la fraude à lutte
contre la fraude qu'elle soit vers les
paradis fiscaux ouvert ou envers les
prestations sociales de rester un combat
permanent pour
pour tous de rester un combat permanent
absolument porte aussi à 2 larsen
le moose voilà
à 2 3
dans le prolongement de ce qu'on dit
tout à l'heure et d'hervé mort et
il est paru dans le prolongement de ce
qu'en dit harvey a fait marrer et padre
joli tout à l'heure
moi je suis aussi étonnée par le peu de
productivité ce n'est pas dans ma papers
par exemple 500 français avaient été
identifiés si j'ai bien compris c'est à
peu près le quart de
des présupposés un t1 intéressés qu'ils
soient en fait une démarche pour se
remettre à jour soit ont été identifiés
par l'administration fiscale est ce
qu'on est vraiment allé au bout de ce
que l'on pouvait faire à votre sens et
sur les paradise paper c'est encore pire
puisque le le produit de redressement il
est quand même extrêmement limité donc
on peut espérer qu effectivement
l'identification des personnes
concernées soit un peu plus active et
puisqu'on a la chance d'avoir une
observatrice européenne je voulais lui
demander quelle était la situation dans
les autres pays européens à ce qu' ils
ont aussi engagé une action résolue pour
lutter contre les paradis fiscaux et
contre l'évasion fiscale
merci michel
merci monsieur le président je moi je
voudrais revenir sur le sur l'accord qui
a été signé la semaine dernière vendredi
dernier sur le avec les 136 pays sur la
nouvelle taxation des multinationales et
qui permet je crois de jeter un pro un
premier gros pavé dans la mare de
l'optimisation fiscale rôle c'est
l'accord est organisé autour de deux
piliers le premier y vise à restreindre
la capacité des paradis fiscaux a
développé par toutes les astuces
juridiques et financières possibles
l'ensemble des mécanismes qui permettent
de découpler artificiellement l'endroit
où un revenu est perçue du lieu où il
est enregistré et donc contrôler et
taxer pour le céder ce premier pilier
pourrait faire en sorte que 125
milliards de dollars de base taxable au
niveau mondiale échappe aux paradis
fiscaux
chaque pays pouvait ensuite axé ses
montants à s'auto nationale
il ya des sommes qui pourraient être
récupérés mais a priori d'ambert dans
des proportions assez faible pour la
france on parle de plusieurs centaines
de millions d'euros enfin il ya un
deuxième volet est qui et quelle plus
belle plus classique qui établit un taux
minimum effectif d'imposition à 15 % des
profits logé à l'étranger par le
multimédia national qui réalise plus de
750 millions d'euros de chiffre
d'affaires donc la conclusion siècle ces
deux nouveaux piliers de la taxation des
multinationales
dans les principes par est
révolutionnaire puisque un état pourra
taxer une entreprise même si elle n'est
pas présente sur son territoire durant
que ses activités ses profits y sont on
peut transférer artificiellement ses
profits dans les paradis fiscaux mais
ils seront in fine est taxé à 15% c'est
vrai que sache c'est un énorme
changement de paradigme dans la façon
d'organiser la taxation des
multinationales et donc à ce sujet j'ai
une question dans un monde de libre
échangisme aujourd'hui n'est-il pas vain
de parler une mesure propre à la france
quand seule une réponse globalisé peut
sembler résoudre la problématique à
l'image de ce qui se passe pour le pour
le climat une approche plus collective
pourrait être me parle me semble-t-il la
seule solution afin que certains pays
cesse lors d'un meeting fiscal est une
certaine harmonisation voit le jour
merci thierry pour ma part je vais me
permettre de peut-être de l'est sur deux
sujets l'homme a été évoquée par madame
alibrandi
concernant la création d'un cadastre des
actifs financiers alors aux deux au delà
de l'idée que l'on comprend quand on
voit des images dont peu c'est moi
j'aimerais bien avoir un petit peu la
vie de monsieur nucci sur la question
c'est à dire sur la concrétisation de ce
concept
qu'en pense l'administration aujourd'hui
et puis une deuxième question plus
générale
en notant que le conseil de l'europe de
l'union européenne après la décision de
sortir trois juridictions de la liste
européenne des états et territoires non
coopératifs
et parmi eux figurent notamment les
seychelles la juridiction qui est
pourtant régulièrement mentionnés dans
les travaux d'investigation donc
certains y ont vu un peu le signe de la
porte est somme toute réduite cette
liste qu'est ce que vous en pensez
voilà je enfin commencer par monsieur
parrinello s'il le veut bien reprendre
les questions qui lui qu'il souhaite
merci beaucoup merci à toutes et à tous
pour toutes ces questions je vais
essayer de répondre un maximum
d'éléments soulever déjà je souhaite
m'associer à
aux remerciements qui ont été prononcées
par des sénateurs dessinatrice au
travail dans l'instigation des
journalistes qui est essentielle et au
courage des lanceurs d'alerté qui dut ou
des lanceurs d'alerté qui ont permis ces
révélations
sur la question des lanceurs d alerte ou
oxfam n'est pas forcément loange est la
plus indiquée pour répondre à ça je vous
renvoie notamment vers les travaux de
transparence y entasse mal et la maison
des lanceurs d alerte un petit point
je pense qu'il ya notamment à faire sur
la chaîne d'alerté qui aujourd'hui
passer systématiquement en interne et
qui peut fragiliser voilà personne voir
la mettre en danger et repenser la
chaîne d'alerté notamment pour pouvoir
une alerte vers les autorités
compétentes mais je vous envoie vraiment
vers les travaux de transparence
international france là dessus
il ya pas mal de questions qui se
recoupent donc je vais je me permettre
de répondre en une fois sur la question
de la liste des paradis fiscaux etc
notamment liée à la question unilatérale
versus multilatérale on peut
effectivement adopter les meilleures
règles possible en france on ne fait
face à des juridictions
opaques
qui n'ont pas forcément un intérêt de
prime abord a changé et c'est tout
l'intérêt d'outils comme les listes de
paradis fiscaux si elles sont assorties
de sanctions c'est à dire comment nous
en place des listes qui ont des critères
objectifs pour viser des pays qui sont
moto roman au pack qui permettent
l'enregistrement de société sans qu'on
sache qui est derrière cette société qui
permettent à des intermédiaires
financiers d'opérer sans mettre en place
des contrôles de lutte anti blanchiment
de lutte antiterroriste qui mettent en
place des pratiques fiscales
dommageables qui finalement exacerbe la
concurrence fiscale déloyale
la liste
dont on entend le plus parler
effectivement c'est la liste de l'union
européenne cette liste elle a une faille
majeure qui a été relevé par parme par
le sénateur bouquet évidemment c'est que
on a certains pays l'union européenne
certains états membres qui eux mêmes
selon les propres critères utilisés
aujourd'hui devrait se trouver sur cette
liste et quelques années oxfam avait
fait une analyse est trouvé qu'il y
avait cinq pays sans que l'état membre
qui aurait dû se trouver sur cette liste
que sont l'irlande le pays bas le
luxembourg malte et chypre
2 2 pays ont été ont été notamment cité
dans les dents les pendants à paris s'il
s'agit du luxembourg il s'agit de chypre
chypre où le président même était
impliqué dans dans certains conseils
financiers donc on voit que des fois
c'est compliqué quand ceux qui sont
censés voter les lois a assuré le cadre
finalement participent des montages mais
c'est un autre sujet mais mais mais tout
ça pour vous dire que évidemment il faut
on peut y aller de manière unilatérale
mais il faut se servir d'outils comme la
liste de paradis fiscaux tant qu'elles
sont basées sur des critères objectifs
ambitieux pour faire changer les autres
pays et le problème aujourd'hui c'est
que ces listes de paradis fiscaux elles
sont trop souvent soumises à des
pressions politiques on a des états qui
sont too big to black list qui sont trop
gros et on n'ose pas y aller et se dire
qu'aujourd'hui on peut améliorer les
critères et c'est nécessaire pour la
liste de paradis fiscaux européenne
puisque aujourd'hui on a des critères de
coopération fiscale donc voici un pays
transferts ces informations fiscales à
d'autres on a des critères de pratiques
fiscales dommageables qui sont
extrêmement réduites et c'est pour ça
que des très gros paradis fiscaux ne
font pas partie de la liste on a des
critères d'application
ddd réforme fiscale internationale mais
on n'a rien par exemple sur la
transparence des bénéficiaires effectifs
on n'a rien sur les règles en place pour
les intermédiaires financiers donc ça
c'est typiquement deux critères simples
qui pourraient être ajoutées avec un
troisième critère qui serait le taux
d'imposition 0 3 critères simples qui
pourraient être ajoutés à une liste à
une miss et qui formerait la base
ensuite évidemment vient la question des
pressions politiques est ce que l'europe
est prête à mettre le dakota du sud dans
une liste grise ou liste noire est ce
que l'europe est prête à mettre le
deleware dans une liste grise ou liste
noire si on se base sur des critères
objectifs oui si cette liste est trop
soumise à des pressions politiques
évidemment c'est un problème et on va se
retrouver dans une situation où on avait
des pratiques fiscales dommageables des
pratiques de blanchiment qui étaient
dans des petits états qui vont se
déplacer vers des gros états qui sont ou
big to black list et donc c'est un
véritable enjeu
sur la question de la chaîne de
responsabilités et des intermédiaires
je vais vous lire le texte de la 5ème
directive anti blanchiment qui fait
qu'aujourd'hui on a toute une myriade
d'acteurs qui arrivent à échapper aux
obligations de contrôle
ses obligations elle de lutte contre le
blanchiment pardon s'applique aux
auditeurs expert comptable externe
conseillers fiscaux et toute autre
personne qui s'engage à fournir
directement ou par le truchement
d'autres personnes auxquelles cette
autre personne est lié une aide
matérielle une assistance ou des
conseils en matière fiscale comme
activité économique aux professionnels
principal tout le problème vient de ce
mot principal c'est pas auction qui lui
dit c'est pas transparence et qui le dit
c'est traque fin qui explique que
certains membres des professions du
chiffre et du droit ont élaboré des
stratégies de contournement en
développant en parallèle de leurs
activités réglementées des entités
juridiquement distinctes qui les exonère
de leurs obligations donc on a certains
certains professionnels intermédiaires
qui ne sont pas soumises à l'obligation
pas ce qu'on appelle le new york est aux
mains de vérifier où son coût son haut
doubien l'argent qui qui qui est à
l'origine derrière et le deuxième enjeu
sur les intermédiaires c'est à dire
qu'aujourd'hui
les reports qui sont faits à trac faim
sont essentiellement sur des personnes
physiques alors même que les personnes
morales représentent l'immense majorité
des cas de corruption on pourrait
imaginer par exemple des reports thing
qui soit faite sur le nombre de
structures sur lesquelles des conseils
ont été faits de structures de
superposition de personnes morales et
derrière le nom de déclaration à tracfin
ça permettrait déjà de voir si un delta
si un delta entre ce qui est et ce qui
est conseillé ce qui est ce qui est
rapporté à un tract
ensuite
sur l'accord international
j'ai le regret de vous dire que ce n'est
pas la fin des paradis fiscaux et
l'évasion fiscale
c'est un c'est un accord qui va je pense
permettre de lutter contre l'utilisation
par les multinationales
donc on parle de multinationales de très
très très très grosse entreprise on ne
parle pas d'une personne qui a une
société écran dans un paradis fiscal où
l'utilisation des boîtes aux lettres ça
oui dans une certaine mesure mais sur le
fameux piliers qui a été mentionné ce
pilier 1 il dresse à dassa de
s'appliquer entre entre 70 et 100
entreprises donc vous imaginez bien que
c'est une en échantillons un confetti
dans
dans l'économie mondiale et sur le taux
d'impôt minimum effectifs à 15 % il ya
pas mal d'exonération qui ont été mises
en place et l'exonération de substances
qui vont permettre aux entreprises
multinationales ne descende leur taux
d'imposition effectif en deçà de 15 %
ceci étant dit je veux pas tout jeter ce
qui est intéressant avec cette cet
accord c'est de voir qu'aujourd'hui on
est passé on est passé à quelques années
finalement d'un d'une logique de dire la
concurrence fiscale c'est juste le
l'effet collatéral du libre échange à
dire la concurrence fiscale déloyale un
impact sur nos sociétés c'est un impact
sur le consentement à l'impôt des ce
n'est plus acceptable et donc on a
réussi à mettre plus d'une centaine de
pays autour de la table c'est pas le
l'aboutissement est
largement de sa des attentes de la
société civile mais le processus de
mettre autant de pays autour de la table
est intéressant il faudrait penser à des
processus similaires notamment sur la
fille la fiscalité des patrimoines qui
est peut-être plus plus en rapport dans
les dents les en europe est parti sur le
registre effet le registre des
bénéficiaires effectifs oui évidemment
qu'il faut le centralisée c'est un des
enjeux après elle toute la difficulté
aujourd'hui c'est déjà de dire que
et qu on a une structure qui utilise une
personne morale en dehors de france bat
ça sort ça sort du registre même donc ça
limite la portée donc oui centralisée et
oui utilisé le bras armé d'une liste
noire de paradis fiscaux et de sanctions
applicables pour forcer les pays qui ne
dévoile pas ses informations à les
dévoiler ça aidera l'administration
fiscale mais ça aidera surtout au
consentement à l'impôt puisque les
citoyens ont la possibilité de contrôler
je crois que j'ai à peu près fait le
tour si ce n'est de dire sur sur les
moyens de la lutte contre l'évasion
fiscale je vais bien évidemment pas me
substituer à monsieur iannucci qu en
dira beaucoup plus que moi mais pour
dire que les mouvements techniques c'est
évidemment quelque chose mais pour faire
des contrôles fiscaux faut des fois des
personnes derrière et donc c'est
important de se rappeler que la
technologie pourra pas nous aider à tout
faire en matière de contrôles fiscaux
voilà le fond merci merci de vos
réponses très complète nous allons
poursuivre avec la madame ali prend 10
elle veut bien
merci beaucoup
journée en prenant le micro
donc merci beaucoup pour vos questions
je vais commencer par
l'utilité des informations pour des
échanges entre les administrations pour
amener quelques pointes de la recherche
donc ce qu'on voit ce que
ces politiques sans vraiment un effet
sur les
dépôts des contribuables offshore mais
il ya des points a souligné qu'ils
peuvent être utiles aussi pour
l'administration on me voit qu'il ya des
mouvements mais on voit aussi que
et les contribuables ils remplacent leur
stratégie par des autres par exemple on
voit qu'il ya en gros sans augmentation
de dépôt aux états unis donc un pays qui
ne partagent pas les informations où on
voit une augmentation des transferts
vers deux autres biens comme par exemple
l'immobilier ou les objets d'art donc
ces mesures devrait être élargi pour
avoir un champ d'action plus large et et
pouvoir compléter ce qui est déjà en
place
ensuite
je viens je rejoins
monsieur palais niel l'eau sur les
commentaires sur la corde l'eau ces
lieux c'est vraiment notable que autant
de pays ont été mis autour de la table
et ils ont alors ils sont arrivés en
conclusion commune
il faut quand même rappeler que c'est là
elle est le fruit de beaucoup de
négociations où il ya eu des concessions
très importantes notamment sur les d
exonération de substance donc on affiche
un taux effectif minimal de 15 % mais en
réalité ces exonérations de substances
sont un peu difficiles à justifier et en
réalité ils baissent ce taux
d'imposition effectif qu'on va avoir sur
les profits des multinationales
je partage aussi l'avis sur la liste des
paradis fiscaux c'est évidemment un
sujet très politique et qui peut être
sensible aussi pour le multilatéralisme
et la coopération entre les différents
pays évidemment toujours là
la voix plus préférable pour résoudre ce
genre de problème c'est la coopération
et le dialogue entre les administrations
et les pays
mais effectivement on voit que
parfois c'est très long et très
compliqué et pendant ce temps là il ya
des autres juridictions qui ont subi des
préjudices et il faut donc que trouver d
autres moyens pour agir contre pour
contraster ces problèmes je vais
conclure avec les le registre de
bénéficiaires effectifs et c'est un
outil qui est très important et je pense
que c'est un cours d'être unifiées au
niveau européen
mais la l'implémentation d'un des
différentes pays c'est
c'est un peu lent donc il ya des pays
qui ont été
plus efficaces
ils ont oublié leur registre
plus vite mais
c'est en cours d'être c'est un cours un
fait est là là l'amélioration de la
qualité des zones et ça sera sûrement
bienvenus
merci merci madame plus longtemps de
maintenance vers monsieur borhnauser je
pense qu'il aura pas mal de de position
par rapport aux questions qui ont été
posées à nous rappeler oui je vais
commencer par répondre à votre question
sur la directive d'axis qui
effectivement a été transposée en droit
français
en mettant dans son champ d'application
avec un certain nombre de réserves mais
en mettant quand même dans son champ
d'application les avocats et les avocats
ne sont pas d'accord avec la manière
dont cette directive a été transposée en
droit français
et comme ils ne sont pas d'accord ils
ont contesté et ils ont saisi le conseil
d'état d'un recours contre l'instruction
qui commentait la transposition de la
direccte la loi transposition de la
directive est manifestement leurs
arguments ont été n'était pas totalement
dépourvue de fondement puisque le
conseil d'état a saisi la cour de
justice de l'union européenne d'une
question préjudicielle
rejoignant ainsi la cour
constitutionnelle belge qui avait elle
même transmis déjà une question
préjudicielle à
la cour de justice à la demande des
barreaux du barreau flamands ou
francophones j'ai oublié de bruxelles
donc tout ça pour vous dire que quand on
va trop loin on cesse pas faire nous les
avocats et il est important que notre
secret professionnel soit protégée parce
que et je lui ai déjà dit en
introduction mais je vais le répéter
parce que je pense qu'il faut marteler
le message notre secret professionnel
n'est pas pour nous protéger nous
exonérer de nos responsabilités il est
là dans l'intérêt des justiciables et
donc dans l'intérêt de la justice
en matière fiscale l'intérêt de la
justice rejoint le consentement à
l'impôt ce consentement à l'impôt qui
est si précieux pour notre démocratie
si le le si les lois ne permettent pas
aux contribuables de les appliquer avec
discernement et dans le respect de leurs
droits fondamentaux de liberté mme qui
sont protégés par notre constitution
alors indirectement mais nécessairement
c'est le consentement à l'impôt lui même
qui est abaissée et c'est extrêmement
grave donc en prenant les avocats pour
cible comme le font un certain nombre de
sénateurs de
domaine j'ai autant de cette table je
pense que vous vous trompez de cible oui
il y à des intermédiaires financiers
qu'ils commercialisent des schémas
frauduleux non il n'y a pas d'avocats
par mieux en tout cas pas d'avocats
français
j'ai entendu ce site est livré à la
vindicte populaire le nom du cabinet
baker & mckenzie qui est cité dans l'est
paradise départ n'aura peppers
je mets au défi de prouver qu'ils ont
mal agi et
et si ils ont mal agi ils seront
sanctionnés mais connaissant la
réputation et la qualité des
professionnels en tout cas en france de
ce cabinet j'en serais personnellement
extrêmement surpris
ça c'était le premier point sur le
sur les comment dire la chaîne de
responsabilités avec les avocats qui
sont mis dedans la deuxième chose que je
voulais dire
concerne la dictature de la transparence
que l'on essaie de nous imposer je vous
rappelle quand même qu'il y a le livre
le respect le droit constitutionnel au
respect de sa vie privée qui fait que le
secret n'est pas honteux des gens ont
des intérêts parfaitement légitime à ne
pas vouloir que leur affaire privée soit
mis sur la place publique donc arrêtons
à vouloir mettre de la transparence
partout c'est vrai en revanche qu'il ya
des catégories de citoyens qui mérite
une place particulière ceux qui aspirent
à exercer des fonctions publiques
doivent s'attendre à ce que les citoyens
scrutent leur affaire privée et ça
paraît être un droit assez fondamental
pour le coup à mettre en oeuvre et on
est face à un problème d'éthique une
frontière à tracer entre
la répression de la fraude d'un côté et
le droit à la liberté au respect de sa
vie privée de l'autre votre honorable
assemblée participent au processus
législatif qui vise à réglementer enfin
comment dire résoudre ces problèmes
d'éthique donc en trouvant la bonne
frontière entre ces principes
contradictoires au dessus de vous il ya
le conseil constitutionnel il ya la cour
de justice de l'union européenne et il y
à la cour européenne des droits de
l'homme qui eux aussi ont leur
conception des choses en espérant
qu'elle soit à peu près similaire mais
il est important de savoir que la
transparence absolue est une folie et je
la dénonce je la dénonce pour le citoyen
lambda qui a le droit au respect de sa
vie privée et de ses placements qu'il ne
doit pas retrouver sur la place publique
le conseil constitutionnel a censuré la
publicité du registre des trusts 1 c'est
pas je vous parle du droit positif là on
peut pas faire n'importe quoi au nom de
la transparence
j'en étais abonné de mon intervention
la défense a terminé
chez lian li pour conclure alors j'ai
l'habitude d'utiliser une formule qui
plaît pas beaucoup mais tant pis je la
réutilisent vous avez toujours une
petite fonction de voix de voiture balai
voyez c'est à dire les questions qu'on
peut éventuellement bénéficier d'une
réponse avec vos prédécesseurs vous êtes
amenés peut-être en fournir une merci je
comprends si le président j'ai un temps
de parole un peu plus long alors pour
essayer de répondre à toutes les
questions six minutes au lieu de sept
j'aurais tout d'abord qu'on fasse bien
distinction entre deux de grands sujets
d'une part la dissimulation de la
matière imposable et d'autre part la
répartition de l'imposition parce que
les sujets qui ont été évoqués récemment
sur l'imposition des multinationales
c'est un sujet de répartition entre
états de la matière imposable il me
semble c'est pas tout à fait le sujet
principal compterait aujourd'hui que
plus la dissimulation notamment de
personnes physiques pour échapper à
l'imposition après il semble qu'il ya un
cheminement intellectuel à respecter
dans notre analyse dans la méthode à la
base de tout il ya les sujets de
connaissances et la de transparence
c'est comment on a les informations
pertinentes et là il ya des progrès
considérables qui ont été faits depuis
au moins une dizaine d'années sur les
échanges automatiques d'informations je
rappelle sa porte sur les comptes sur
les revenus et la localisation pays par
pays de l'activité économique
point fondamental qui est évoquée sur
les bénéficiaires effectifs
alors c'est pas seulement un sujet
fiscal c'est un sujet anti blanchiment à
la base mais en france c'est un système
très très aboutie tenus par les
greffiers qui en accès direct et gratuit
par tout le monde alors après comme
toujours un lien il ya un sujet de
qualité des données et c'est vrai que
c'est toujours perfectible sur
l'actualisation des données les mises à
jour mais ça existe ça existe au niveau
de l'union européenne sur les
bénéficiaires effectifs
le gafi s'est emparé du sujet
au niveau mondial et donc c'est des
sujets aussi qui progresse parce que le
point déterminant c'est de savoir
quelles sont les personnes physiques qui
sont derrière les écrans et les
personnes morales et tant qu'on n'a pas
cette information
on peut quand même pas fait à grand
chose dans l'accès à l'information donc
il ya le sujet d'accise qui est évoquée
sur les déclarations de montage donc ça
c'est un point important et qui a qui
devraient avoir essentiellement un effet
dissuasif sur les montages les plus
agressifs comme monsieur borhnauser l'a
dit les avocats ne font tous les recours
possibles et imaginables
ce qui serait indigne et d'être dans le
champ de la directive et d'être
considérés comme des intermédiaires
c'est une situation qui me surprend un
peu parce que la cour européenne des
droits de l'homme et quand même
clairement distinguer l'activité de
conseil de l'activité de défense
notamment à l'arrêt michaud dans le
conseil c'est un positionnement de
l'avocat qui est différent ce qui est
très en amont pour conseiller un client
en caricaturant d'un certain cas il le
conseille pour commettre ce qui pourrait
être une infraction donc on n'est pas du
tout dans l'activité de défense
juridictionnelle qui elle justifie
pleinement l'étendue du secret
professionnel
donc voilà ça c'est pour nous un ascète
d'enjeux de sanctuariser
tout le secret professionnel y compris
sur le conseil parce que ça ça nous
prive quand même de moyens d'accès à
l'information donc la notion de cadastre
sur les actifs financiers
ça participe je l'imaginé de cette
logique en jeu se connaît pas les
contours exacts du projet mais voilà
c'est effectivement comment on peut
avoir une vision complète
pour ce qui est de la fiscalité de la
matière imposable et de la localisation
dans les pays
donc
problème de qualité des informations et
après on arrive à l'analyse des
informations et c'est là que justement
ça permet de distinguer autant que faire
se peut le légal de l'illégal
donc sûr si on considère que regard des
informations
tout ce système à l'information ça
conduit souvent à conclure que les
informations avaient déjà été portés à
la connaissance des administrations donc
ça explique aussi en partie le taux de
déchets qu'on a entre le nombre de
personnes identifiées donc par le
consortium de journalistes et le nombre
de procédures qu'on engage stack à des
gens qui oui on une société à l'étranger
mais il l'avait indiqué il ont un compte
à l'étranger il l'avait indiqué déclarer
les revenus et donc bien évidemment si
ces gens là sont en règle on va pas
faire de redressement
donc voilà après quand on est sur une
situation qu'on considère comme illégale
il ya un arsenal législatif
qui est assez étendue vous l'avez évoqué
monsieur le président à l'article 209
bis donc en fait l'arsenal qui consiste
soit à
imposer en france un bénéfice qui
optiquement est réalisée en structure
étrangère soit à rejeter la déduction
d'une charge en france sur des flux qui
vont vers vers l'étranger et donc moi
l'impression que j'ai c'est que la
france était plutôt en avance sur ce que
pourraient être des standards
internationaux et donc à cannes arsenal
assez développée et qui est utilisé à
année par année par les directions de de
contrôle
donc voilà donc les procédures on l'est
on les a donc il ya beaucoup de droit de
communication à d'assistance
administrative et comme je disais une
coordination avec l'autorité judiciaire
qui est de plus en plus fortes et qui
permet justement de combiner nos accès
à l'information
alors dans les questions qui sont posées
effectivement il y avait un sentiment de
déception dans l'administration fiscale
ne fait que tant de redressement mais
donc je pense que c'est inhérent on peut
au cheminement que j'ai indiquées il ya
forcément un taux de déchet ce n'était
pas le bon terme et un taux de pertes
entre l'information brute et le point
auquel on arrive donc sur les pandora
peppers on oscille 600 personnes
françaises moi j'ai pas la liste de
toutes les 600 personnes à ce jour j'ai
quelques noms ici ou là dont certains ne
sont pas des résidents français donc
quand on aura cette liste on regardera
et puis on verra s'il ya des personnes
ne sont pas en conformité avec leurs
leurs obligations et
mais voilà on est plus en plus quand
même dans un système dissuasif
les gens ça et on l'a vu sur les
régularisations comptes à l'étranger qui
les risques d'être rattrapé par
l'administration fiscale
on a beaucoup d'eau 6 2
de régularisation
sur les moyens qu'on engage sur ces
opérations
je rappelle que bon on a une direction
nationale des enquêtes fiscales
qui coordonne appelé les actions de
recherche qui va elle même chercher de
l'information secrète je n'aurais pas
non plus qu on ait l'impression qu'on ne
travaille qu'avec des informations
fournies par les journalistes et on est
tenu par le secret fiscal donc on veut
pas faire état de tout ce qu'on fait
mais il ya des dossiers qu'on est allé
chercher nous mêmes il y en a qui était
rendu public il fallait déjà une dizaine
d'années mais le dossier hsbc avec 3000
détenteurs de comptes à l'étranger c'est
le travail de l'administration
de convaincre une personne faible
de traiter avec une personne pour
qu'elle nous donne des informations
donc là il ya tout un travail qui n'est
pas forcément très très visible mais qui
nous engage
au quotidien
sur
parce que voilà il donne toujours
l'impression d'être en retrait j'ai une
question étant allé au bout de ce qu'on
peut faire on peut toujours aller plus
loin
je suis pas convaincu sincèrement que ce
soit un problème d'effectif humain le
défi qu'on a c'est de traiter une
volumétrie d'information considérable et
donc il nous faut des outils
technologies pour traiter cette masse
d'informations et justement cibler les
contrôles on ne contrôle pas par hasard
le chant est infinie il faut savoir où
chercher
pour être efficace alors après au moins
voilà je pas mais le vote la condition
je suis fonctionnaire c'est toujours
mieux d'avoir plus de moyens que moi je
ne suis pas convaincu que si on avait le
doubs de vérificateurs on aurait des
résultats deux fois plus élevé c'est pas
aussi simple il faut éviter les
raccourcis trop trop saisissant
donc bien entendu il faut des réponses
globalisé haut niveau non seulement
refermer mondiale
donc on voit bien les limites on peut
faire beaucoup de choses sur le
territoire français après c'est beaucoup
plus long et difficile
à l'extérieur donc moi je me prononcerai
pas sur la liste des paradis fiscaux
c'est pas de mon niveau de
fonctionnaires nous ce qu'on essaye de
regarder c'est justement l'effectivité
de la coopération de ces pays c'est non
seulement est ce qu'ils répondent à nos
questions mais ce qu'ils répondent bien
il faut se méfier aussi de l'effet de
décalage temporel c'est à dire que les
affaires qui sont révélées on a souvent
des données qui remontent à plusieurs
années en arrière
certains de ces paradis fiscaux nous
assure
maintenant de leur bonne foi de leur
volonté dans un système
international transparent alors je ne
sais pas s'ils sont sincères ou pas mais
s'ils le sont ça leur demande un peu
aussi de temps et
il faut qu'on apprécie la clé
l'effectivité de leur action est ce
qu'ils se donnent les moyens dans leurs
législations internes d'accéder aux
informations financières donc qu' il ya
un cheminement qui est compliqué à entre
l'âme la liste hausser de la liste union
européenne l'osce et de accepte de hrw
est de faire des revues périodiques
ce qui dans certains cas en fait
dans certains de ces cas l'union
européenne
comment dire rétrograde un peu le pays
dans sa
danse et liste passe de la grise noix de
la liste noire la liste grise donc sans
que ce soit forcément non plus un
jugement définitif sur
sur le pays
e
voilà ce que je voulais dire
j'insiste quand même sur les sujets sur
les intermédiaires et notamment les
avocats ben c'est pas les avocats qui
sont pris pour cible ce sont les avocats
qui prennent pour cible la législation
anti anti évasion anti fraude et de
manière assez violente au nom de sujets
en fin de grand principe que je
comprends tout à fait dès qu'ils en
matière fiscale me semble un peu en
décalage par rapport à ce qui est
l'essence de la profession d'avocat
[Musique]